- Well, speaking of birthdays,
so "Boys in the Hood," is
it the 30th anniversary?
(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Yes,
yeah-
- Last summer?
- Something like that, yeah.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
(Kelly's voice drowns)
- I mean,
the film, it just,
such a pop culture-
- I was only 10.
(Kelly laughing)
So if you do the math,
(Kelly's hands tapping)
if you do the math,
it's-
- Yeah.
Oh heck, God, no!
But it's, why do you think
people resonated so much then?
And honestly, unfortunately,
still resonate with it now.
- You know, it's interesting
because first of all,
shout out to the great,
late great John Singleton,
he was incredible.
He was just a
(crowd cheering and clapping)
great visionary.
- Yeah.
- But I think a lot of the themes still
are very prevalent to this day.
- Which kinda sucks.
- It does, yeah, it really does.
And then, he put together,
it was a great script that he wrote,
he directed a great
movie, and he assembled
a great cast of people who
were just really good people.
And it's, it was just an
incredible project to be a part of.
- Yeah, I mean, I can imagine,
especially as an actor,
like, it's cool to be a
part of something that just
hits pop culture in such
a way, but also has such
an important message.
- Without a doubt.
I mean, to think now that people
are still talking about it,
it's, when I did that movie
so many years ago, I mean,
I just wanted to be a part of something,
I just wanted to get a job, I
just wanted to be in a movie,
and there's no way I
thought that it would be,
people would still be talking
about it to this very day.
So, it's a blessing.